It's not just me who feels the pressure, the
whole society feels the pressure. If
thousands of people and tens of thousands of people
came together in this square to react to the pressure, there
are serious problems in the economy and the problems make the society uneasy in a sense.
We
will bring both freedom and democracy to our own country. There
is a serious field in the columns of Turkey.  There
is serious damage in the main columns of democracy, which we call legislative, judiciary and executive. We
want to fix it.
I want to be the President and I want
to make Turkey a truly democratic country.
Therefore,
we will prepare a damage assessment report.
Because Turkey is now largely no longer a transparent state,
can you come and meet
our obligations?  We don't know these, it
is not right to make decisions about Turkey's future without knowing the numbers. He would put the real picture of Turkey in front of the leaders within a month or at the
latest 1 month and 15 days.
After that,
make decisions. We will start with Maya
with descriptions. You know,
Hafez
will be the President of the painters. I say this everywhere,
even if he votes.  Even if it doesn't, I
need to reconcile Turkey. If there is
no good governance and a top view.
Plus, if
you treat all citizens equally. If you bring justice to everyone who wants justice. If you give justice to everyone who wants justice. The
state will be transparent. If you
account for the taxes collected,
they will see how good a ruler we
are. After a while,
they will come to our side.  There
will also be an increase in their income,
income per capita will rise. Interest rates will
fall. They will
see that Turkey is governed better and they will start to sympathize with us. We
want to be a part of it. We want democracy in our country, we do not want an authoritarian government and we want freedom.
Young people and women are greatly
bored, they also want freedom.
Therefore, We are Europe.  We will bring
all the democratic rules stipulated by the Union to our
own country.
Our relations with the west will develop within democratic standards, our
connections will be stronger.
We will continue our relations with Russia, as we have in the past. Because many Turkish
businessmen have investments there, but we do not want
Russia to
invade Ukraine.  We are against
it and we don't find it right,
so
Erdogan has a month to do his duty as the leader of a party.
[Music] I
have never seen a second person in my life who lies as much as he does, he
distorts the facts and makes all kinds of
smears, but no matter what he does, the
people's choice will be on my side. I
wish we don't appear on television programs.  If
I have the courage,
I will upload it
to your profile like
[Music]